hi I'm Rachel today I wanted to bring in
some people to talk
about their histories with substance
abuse and how they were able to change
their life for the better and maybe
hopefully inspire some of you guys to be
able to have this conversation and
alleviate a little bit of that stigma
the point I realized I had a problem was
when I wasn't living up to my fullest
potential as a human being I was unable
to show up for life
I was unable to show up as a friend as a
daughter as a sister as an employee I
knew that if I continued living a
certain way I was gonna be dead before I
hit 30 I felt that I could stop anytime
and then I realized I couldn't I was
living with my aunt in her basement and
I was mad at my aunt for having an
attitude problem with me very I called
her and I was like I think I have a
problem and the moment I said it I was
trying to scheme her the moment I said
it I remember I started sobbing and I
was like oh no I I have a problem it was
really difficult for me to consider
myself someone struggling with addiction
until I actually began the recovery
process it was something that was like
really hard for me to grapple with
I'd woken up one morning and I looked in
the mirror and I was like I don't want
to be that person anymore I honestly
don't know if there was one specific
moment that I can pinpoint but I do know
that there were just a lot of lows and I
got to a point where I was I just felt
so broken inside I wasn't sure if if
something so broken could really ever be
fixed I think even when I realized I had
a problem I didn't know if I necessarily
wanted help yet I think the moment I
actually wanted to change my life and
wanted to actually feel better is when I
saw other people going through recovery
of whatever whatever way that they were
or whatever they were recovering from I
saw that and was like oh I don't have to
be miserable I don't have to hate
everything I don't have to always think
that everyone's a threat like I can be
happy a few years ago when I was
babysitting my stepdaughter I did so so
many drugs and and I drank so much that
my hands were shaking and I could not
control the fact that my hands were
shaking and I remember I had to feed my
stepdaughter my house was too shaky to
feed her so he was I realized like I
need to stop I need to get better in
order to feed her that day it hit me
like what am i doing
[Music]
what worked for me was I went away to
treatment I needed to go away and
physically get out of my environment
that I was in but when I came back from
treatment I I sought out the help of
12-step rooms and that just has worked
for me for the past few years
[Music]
I was in therapy and the therapist
recommended that I check out a meeting
and I didn't really think that it was
for me honestly I thought that like that
was too much and I didn't think I was on
that level so I didn't really give it a
fair shot and it didn't work at first
like it was really difficult for me to
get it things got really really bad
again as they always did and so I gave
it another try
and that time I for some reason was
willing to try recovery is such a
fragile and personal thing I think it
really is different for everybody and I
know so many people who who do it you
know in different ways and it's just
about like finding what works I think
for you when I was looking for help I
think the most beneficial thing was
telling people I needed help I had so
many people calling places saying like
can we get her in here can we do this
blah and I remember I had a choice of
like going to a halfway house in Harlem
or staying at my aunt's house and I
remember I initially made the choice of
going to the halfway house in Harlem
because I was going to go right back
into what I was doing I had like I think
60 days off all my meds and stuff like
that
and I made the decision to actually stay
with my aunt even though I was really
embarrassed and didn't want to and I
stayed in her basement I got picked up
everyday by like this van and I went so
like an outpatient recovery thing for
mental health and I did that I think for
like six weeks and it was so great just
to talk to people all day and I think
like I just kept going to new things
after that I went into like the rooms
after that I went and like made friends
that like we're doing the same thing I
was doing and like all that sort of
stuff like friends who didn't know me
and like I don't have to get embarrassed
with basically like just know that there
are so many different routes you don't
have to do the route that I did or
Alyssa did or anything like that and
there are so many different ways that's
basically just what's up to the
individual person and how they want to
go about doing it my best friend
actually my best friend and also my
brother they actually set
like I needed somebody to understand
what I'm saying listening to the words
I'm saying stuffing and the feelings
that I was feeling at the moment
that's what I needed the most I didn't
really need a I didn't really need
12-step I didn't need none of those
thing what I needed was to be treated
like a human being it was just to be
hurt
it was hard to get away from something
that took me away for a moment of being
present but I'm also trying to look at
the at the fact that I am clean that I
am changing and that life is different
I'm in a whole different environment
I love remembering what I did yesterday
what I did today and remembering what
I'm gonna do tomorrow and that's
something that I never did in the
beginning of my recovery it was awful
because I lost that other thing that was
feeling me my entire life which was my
ego I just lost it
[Music]
alcohol's the social lubricant and so
for the first like year so my sobriety
it was a little bit hard by going out
and just connecting with other people
and really not making it about his
substance making it about that human
connection I just it just changed my
world I think in terms of triggers for
me I mean they're everywhere in the
beginning it was a lot harder to be
around like anyone who is drinking or
using and these days like I'm a little
bit better because I have tools that I
know I can use if I'm in a situation
where I feel really triggered I pick up
a phone instead of picking up a drink
like there are just things that I've
sort of learned was crazy about not
giving it
is that you get tested all the time well
you don't want it right there I think
what I've done recently is just I look
at that and I'm just like I know the
doors that's gonna there have been lots
of different moments where I felt
defeated I mean it this is probably the
hardest thing that I've ever done I
don't know about you but like it's just
like it feels like a constant battle
with my inner demons and it gets better
and it has gotten so much better and so
much easier because I've learned
different tools and I've met different
people and I think that making those
connections has made it a lot easier but
yeah it's it's absolutely something that
I take one day at a time I can be a
daughter today to my parents can be a
good job as a sister my friendships are
better I didn't have frankly I didn't
have relationships when I was you know a
hot mess my relationships are so full
and rich today I'm I'm building up a
relationship with myself I'm like
repairing the relationships that I
ruined in my using and in my addiction
that's really like all of what life is
for to me is like the connections that
we have with other people in our lives
and for so long I was just sabotaging
those and sort of like self-destructing
all of them because I I was like out of
control and I didn't I didn't know how
to have a healthy relationship my
relationships are so different I mean my
friends family like I'm not even nervous
to anyone you can be I can be a shoulder
for you to lean on it doesn't matter
because I'm so secure myself and knowing
knowing that I can now also say because
that big ego part of me is gone like hey
I messed up or hey this knowing that
like I'm just a person and I'm literally
trying my best
doing things like this and helping other
people reaching out to others not
putting myself in those same situations
I think a lot of the people and things
that I was associating with kind of had
to stay back in that old life the thing
that has helped me stay sober is that
I'm partially blind in my left eye I
don't see the world as I used to but I'm
more open there are three key things
that I've kept me sober and this is just
me personally playing the tape forward
so just like knowing all right if I take
that drink then what's gonna happen x
y&z are going to happen if I take that
drink or drug to having something to be
accountable to it is so important and
crucial and three like reaching out to
other people and like there's a whole
community of other sober people out
there I think that what has kept me from
using again is honestly like 12-step
recovery is really a huge part of this
journey for me and the community that
I've found there
[Music]
the person has to be done it doesn't
mean don't do anything before I remember
my friends and my family came to me and
I was like like before I knew had a
problem and I was like okay you can't
force anyone to do anything it has to be
a personal choice at the end of the day
if it's not your choice it's not gonna
work like I was like a nightmare of a
human until I rise like oh I have a
problem in order to help someone who is
struggling you have to just be there and
don't judge them I know you want to
judge them but save it even when I see
people now struggling like you
automatically get like that so mad at
you want to get it together but it's
like why am i doing that I'm not any
better than you like you're just having
to be struggling at this moment in time
it could be me tomorrow be a gentle
loving source just always either do not
suffocate them at the end of the day
they're gonna do what they're going to
want to do and I truly believe that a
person will that help and want to get
help my karate for people that don't
know how to do with an adit I would say
sit down and just listen to them that's
all they really need listen be patient
you know we're gonna fail a few times
we're all human we fail I fail so many
times never give up on that win I think
there's a lot of misconceptions about
people who are sober I think there's
like a dirty word around addicts and
alcoholics I'm young I got sober and my
life wasn't over in fact it gave me life
back I've seen so many people around me
like affected by addiction whether it be
just even like their loved ones and it's
not happening to them and they have kind
of no idea what to do and I think that's
what happened for me like I realized I
had a problem then all of a sudden I was
like how do I even navigate any of this
like I don't even know who to talk to I
help as an addict I just feel like it's
important to be raw about your
situations I lived in a world where I
believed I didn't deserve hope I know
that when I was going through all of my
struggles and like the trials and
tribulations of figuring out this whole
addiction journey it was really helpful
for me to see people who were in
recovery in the public eye and it was
really inspiring to me and I remember
wondering how they did it and wondering
how they got there and wondering how
they got help it's a really vulnerable
thing but it's definitely something that
I want to be able to help other people
with nothing should really be weird for
us to talk about like we should just be
able to say like I'm having a hard time
because I may have a hard time six
months from now and then I'll be fine
and all that sir stuff but I need to be
able to talk and be open and it's really
different for everyone but we don't have
to make it some big secret
[Music]
you
[Music]
you